For one-dimensional collisions,
let's talk about two objects, 1
and object 2, moving with
velocity V1 and another object
V2 moving with velocity V2.
Let's say they're
moving on the ground.
Now I'd like to introduce the
concept of relative velocity,
a concept that we experience
all the time in our lives.
But let's see what
it actually means.
So V relative, I'm
going to define
this to be the velocity of
V1 minus the velocity of V2.
Now because of this minus
sign that seems a little bit
about abstract.
But one typical example where
we see this all the time
is for people
traveling on highways.
You might have two cars, one
car overtaking the other car.
But if you're
sitting in car 1, it
looks like car 2 is
going quite slow.
So let's just take
typical highway example.
So you might have V1.
And we'll give it some speed.
So we'll make it
60 miles per hour.
And we'll just call this
one-dimensional problem i hat.
And V2-- notice
we're not speeding
on a highway-- V2 is going
at 50 miles per hour,
i hat, very slow.
And the relative velocity,
V1 minus V2-- so that's
what we're calling V relative--
that's 60 miles per hour
minus 50 miles per hour i hat.
And that's just
10 miles per hour.
And that's what people
experience when one car is
approaching another car.
If you're in car 2, car
1 seems like it's coming
at you at 10 miles per hour.
This is what we mean
by relative velocity.
There's another
important example--
so that's example 1-- the other
important example to look at,
example 2, is when
two objects are
moving in opposite directions.
So let's just see write them in
terms of components this time.
So we have V2 x1.
And we have V2.
And let's make V1 x positive.
So object 1 is moving
in that direction.
And let's write
this one as V2 x.
We don't have to
call this initial.
We'll just call it V2 x i hat.
And here V2 x is
equal to minus V1 x.
So its component is negative.
And even though we drew
an arrow in this picture,
the picture is still fine,
because if the component is
negative, it means it's moving
in the opposite direction.
The key arrow is the unit vector
when we are writing components.
And now V relative in this case
is V1 x i hat minus V2 x i hat.
That's the V1 x i
hat minus minus.
So there's another V1 x i hat.
So the relative
velocity in this case
has a component that's
twice the speed of V1.
If two objects are moving
together at the same speed,
the relative velocity,
the way we've defined it,
has twice the magnitude
of either velocity.
And this is an important example
to consider in collisions.
Now this relative velocity
concept we'll see we'll
add a new way of thinking
about elastic collisions
with no external forces
in one dimension.